mientras el reloj avanza en los últimos
intentos de llegar a un acuerdo
comercial post break sheet el último
obstáculo podría ser uno que domina las
conversaciones desde el principio las
reglas de juego equitativas el problema
está en el corazón del break si la parte
británica insiste en la soberanía
mientras que bruselas dice que la
competencia abierta y justa es
primordial reinounido abandona el
mercado único de la unión europea y la
unión aduanera a fin de año durante
meses los negociadores han intentado
acordar cómo funcionará el comercio
entre las dos partes después de esa
fecha para ello se discute un conjunto
de reglas y estándares que garantizan
que las empresas de un país no tengan
ventaja competitiva sobre las de otro la
unión europea quiere que estas reglas se
apliquen a toda regulación sobre
derechos laborales medioambiente
impuestos y ayudas estatales
bruselas insiste en que reino unido no
puede tener el mejor acceso al mercado
único si se aparta de estas regulaciones
dando a las empresas británicas ventajas
comerciales sobre sus rivales europeos
la unión europea es el mayor socio
comercial del reino unido- el año pasado
las exportaciones británicas de la unión
fueron de 325 mil millones de euros 43%
de las exportaciones totales las
importaciones del reino unido- de la
unión europea fueron de 414 mil millones
de euros 52 por ciento de todas las
importaciones británicas boris johnson
quiere decidir las reglas y las
regulaciones de reino unido pero también
quiere un acuerdo sin aranceles ni
cuotas ha criticado a la unión europea
por no ofrecer un acuerdo comercial
similar al que tiene con canadá pero
bruselas dice que reino unido debe estar
sujeto a las reglas más estrictas como
una de las economías más grandes del
mundo y una que ya está estrechamente
vinculada a los mercados europeos